les attentats du 11 septembre ont frappé
new york en plein coeur de ses activités
causant même la fermeture complète de
ces bourses aspect dramatique de ce qui
s'est passé a très largement dominé nous
avions quand même des centaines de morts
le problème par exemple d'un manque de
sens dans le contexte les parquet new
yorkais ont décidé de fermer pendant
toute une semaine du jamais vu dans
l'histoire un certain nombre
d'opérateurs et leur client n'aurait pas
été en mesure d'agir sur la bourse alors
que d'autres auraient pu le faire ça
crée une inégalité qui étaient
totalement inacceptables
la réouverture lundi 7 septembre a
suscité beaucoup d'émotion à la fois une
tristesse profondes
de ce qui s'était passé
mais j'allais dire une rage de vivre un
besoin de recommencer nous ne pouvions
pas nous laisser abattre il fallait
remettre le marché en route il fallait
que l'économie se remette en route mais
avec l'incertitude l'adar jones a perdu
7% la première journée et plus de 14%
durant la semaine les chocs dans
l'histoire c'est pas le premier mais ça
sera pas le dernier comme on vient de le
vivre et on est en train de revivre tous
les chocs sont similaires surprenant
imprévus et
créer l'instabilité
en fait les marchés étaient des gens
correction avec l'éclatement de la bulle
technologique l'événement servi de
catalyseur ou d'accélérateur de la
correction quand un événement comme ça
arrive concentrez-vous sur des bonnes
compagnies parce que les bonnes
compagnies finissent par passer à
travers c'est ce que vous vous laissez
passer à travers la tempête
un mois plus tard les indices était déjà
revenue au niveau d'avant les attentats
notre autre grâce à l'intervention
musclée de la réserve fédérale
américaine qui a réduit les taux
d'intérêt et surtout injecter 200
milliards de liquidités dans le système
sûr ça fait en sorte de créer
confiance sur les marchés qui éviter que
ça tourne en quelque chose depuis hier
je pense qu'on a été très efficace les
compagnies aériennes elles ont vu le
trafic aérien' plongé de 35% aux états
unis aujourd'hui quand on le compare
avec la pandémie ça nous paraît moins
important n'empêche qu'à l'époque on
n'avait jamais connu un tel effondrement
et on ne savait pas quoi faire face à
cet effondrement l'a d'ailleurs à peine
deux semaines après les attentats le
congrès accordait une aide de 10
milliards à l'industrie aérienne la
majorité de ces compagnies là qui ont
dit qu'ils étaient en difficulté qui
sont demandé de l'aide au gouvernement
fédéral à l'époque il était déjà en
situation de difficultés financières
avant des attentats tous secteurs
confondus près de 200000 américains ont
perdu leur emploi après les attentats
nous quelques mois plus tard l'économie
s'était déjà relevé le fait pas et et
persistants a annoncé choc était
concentrée dans le temps qui était
beaucoup d'impact pour la ville de new
york qui était beaucoup plus important
évidemment mais pour l'économie en
général
la relance américain n'a par contre a
mis certains changements structuraux
dans l'économie les attaques du 11
septembre ont accéléré peut-être des
phénomènes qui allait se produire de
toute façon
mais les ont certainement accéléré 2011
notion de profit des entreprises
devaient trouver une solution pour
raviver les profits est une des
solutions c'est d'utiliser l'entrée de
la chaîne à noël c'est pour faire une
relocalisation de la production
washington s'est aussi lancé dans une
déréglementation pour favoriser la
relance ça a peut-être mené un certain
excès que nord connue en 2005-2006
d'innovation financière qui est un moins
encadrées et qui a mené à cette
arrestation de 2007-2008 soit la grande
récession
sans oublier que les états unis ont
dépensé depuis 2001 six mille milliards
de dollars pour la sécurité intérieure
et la lutte contre le terrorisme mais
c'est marie claude morin radio canada
montréal
[Musique]
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne i see her dit